the return of Tom Hanks the burbs baby
the burbs Larry Crowne which is really
nothing like the burbs want to get that
out there where so Larry Crowne was
actually directed by Tom Hanks and it
was written by Tom Hanks and that chick
who wrote My Big Fat Greek Wedding so it
sounds like it's made by a couple people
who know what's going on so Larry crowns
about a guy played by Tom Hanks named
Larry Crowne who works in a retail store
and he's like the nicest guy ever like
to an absurd degree he's just always
smiling he's always happy it's like that
guy that you look at and you're like I
wish I knew more of those people you're
looking yourself you're like I'm a piece
of [ __ ] cuz I'm nothing like that guy I
should be so the corporate guys who run
the company he works for downsize and
they fire him he's like the perfect
employee and they just cannon which if
you've ever worked retail you understand
because you know every retail chain is
run by snakes douche bags and [ __ ]
all of them I've worked retail so I know
I hope they're watching and so in order
to be fireproof Tom Hanks gets the idea
that he should go to school for the
first time ever it's like a 40-something
year old guy he's never been to school
so now he's off to college and then the
movie ensues now I've seen some reviews
for this movie and they're like oh it's
not that funny or as a romantic comedy
he just fails well it's not a comedy and
I would barely call it a romantic comedy
you're right if it's one of those two it
does fail it's about a guy named Larry
Crowne who's going through some
self-discovery and he's affecting people
around him and whatnot you know good
[ __ ] like that although it does have
romantic comedy type things in it now
when he first gets to school he meets
this chick who it was like really cute I
don't know who she is except she was in
that show called Undercovers that was
like cancelled after blogging episode
and a half like did screwed Julia
Roberts go after that Jay guy so she's
like 27 years younger than Tom Hanks but
hey I think he could have convinced her
it's a good idea she's odd she was not
sandwiches and she's really cool and
really good for Tom Hanks she's like
this free spirit she's like you live
only once try everything once just enjoy
life and he's pretty much like tofu like
he picks up the flavors of whatever's
around him and so I was like okay I'll
hang out with you you want me to join
your probably gay moped biker gang from
the Wiz I am in favor of a biker gang
who rode mopeds probably gay and he
never has a romance with this chick this
chicks just someone he hangs out with
and Tom Hanks ultimately takes two
college courses this semester one taught
by Julia Roberts the other taught by
George Takei and he is attracted to one
of them sorry my gay demographic he's
attracted to Julia Roberts so
now Julia Roberts when I first saw her
in this movie I'm like she is such a
drag I mean you're on such an up from
Larry crowns character you like him and
you're like yeah dude I'm feeling good
this guy is awesome then Julia Roberts
is like gray the entire time you're like
oh I'm coming down from that high but
you understand why she's miserable
because she's married to Heisenberg from
Breaking Bad who plays a former rider
slash blogger slash unemployed douchebag
it's like all the negative aspects of
Hank Moody from Californication - any
success ability to get chicks or
likability in general he's a douchebag
and she's married to him so you
understand why she's miserable
but the really intriguing part of the
movie was just watching Larry Crowne
evolve and then if I care you make like
Julia Roberts feel better although they
don't really spend a lot of time
together at all except for in the
classroom
in fact you're unaware that there's too
much of an attraction between the two
until like the half an hour's left in
the movie which is why I say it's not
really a romantic comedy rather a movie
about live via the eyes of Larry Crowne
Larry Crowne starts dressing shark by
the end of the movie he starts out like
khakis and polos and whatnot by the end
he's wearing stuff and I'm like I want
to wear that I'm going to the men's
warehouse tomorrow and I'm picking up
the Larry Crowne Collection let's do
this so if you're looking for a
hilarious comedy it's not really this if
you're looking for a rom-com it's kind
of this the movie had some funny moments
in it I'll give it that but if you're
looking for a movie like Garden State
for 40-something year olds
this is it this movie gets it I would
say it's a good time no alcohol required
this movie surprised the hell out of me
it's a good feel good movie you walk out
of there you're like I want to be better
I just want to be a better person I
don't got a buy it on blu-ray I'll buy
it on blu-ray what I need to buy it on
blu-ray in about 15 years I think the
movie is tailored for people who are
going through a midlife crisis and it
makes you kind of want to go to school
too because you like the interaction
that you just saw it's kind of like when
you wanted to become a doctor after you
watch scrubs and you look into it and
you're like screw that [ __ ] I ain't
doing this anymore that's way too
exhausting so Larry Crowne got fired
from his job what's the job that you've
had where you're like I can't believe
I'm doing this I hate this [ __ ] I want
to quit hopefully I just get fired
comment below let me know and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more